also tonight a community gathers to  remember a young mother stabbed and  killed last night good evening to you at  11. thanks for joining us I'm Brian  Loftus the family of 21 year old  Michaela Adams organized this vigil  which happened near Bonanza and MLK  Michaela's mother telling us that she  and her husband found her dead inside  their home last night but thankfully  also found her baby unharmed her family  was very thankful that the community is  able to support them in the wake of this  tragedy she would be very proud to know  the people actually  because you didn't think anybody could  and she just became a new mom  she loved that baby more than anything  in this world  meanwhile the man accused of killing her  24 year old Michael Ricks was captured  earlier today in San Diego California